bonjour à tous donc
côté c'était ans l'ancien
sa voix et c était là
la première session qui a été formé au
bourget du lac en 92
avant j'étais j'avais fait juste le
bizutage de lenny de belfort ça m'avait
bien plu j'étais venu ici pour faire un
autre bizutage et ensuite pour me former
dans le domaine du bâtiment
quand on commence
là dessus quand on est étudiant
j'imagine que vous communiquez pas
forcément beaucoup ce nid sur vos
activités extra scolaires ni si vos
résultats à vos parents et j'avais un
binôme avec qui je travaillais en
travaux pratiques qui habitait pas très
loin de chez moi qui passe me voir
pendant les vacances très sympa et maman
très inquiète
alors qu'hier comment ça se passe à
l'école il est quand même pour les
renier
non il est pro dernier il avant dernier
et donc et ben en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que je m'occupais le journal
de l'école du bureau des élèves de la
caf et beaufortain qui existent plus
j'ai fait le bizutage ici mais j'ai
plutôt que des finances afin de faire
défiler un sac poubelle et en crème à
raser des gens je leur ai proposé en 93
de nettoyer la laisse du bourget du lac
jusqu'à chambéry
mais sur 104 personnes il y en a cent
deux qui sont venus volontairement alors
qu'il pleuvait il faisait pas très beau
donc voilà et moi ça me plaisait bien de
faire les choses un petit peu autrement
et puis le vendredi le mercure le mardi
je faisais du volet le jeudi je faisais
de l'aviron le samedi et le dimanche
j'allais faire de la randonnée et puis
de temps en temps la nuit jallet
emballer des pâtes alpina mais j'ai
toujours été présent concours très frais
mais toujours présent après ce que j'ai
expliqué à mes parents c'est globalement
des major de promo il y en avait déjà 3
qui se tiraient la bourre pour être
premier en ramener un quatrième ça
allait mettre du désordre
donc cette époque forcément la bonne
idée si je prends un petit peu de recul
aujourd'hui les majors ils sont
responsables d'une agence chez vinci et
eiffage dans un office hlm ils font du
report thing toute la journée sur des
tableaux excel
moi ça fait 15 ans que je me fais
plaisir à faire de la technique j'aime
bien la technique et c'est un fait ça ça
j'ai oublié de vous dire maintenant ce
que j'ai fait
à 19 ans m'a dit que j'avais un cancer
de la peau que j'ai bien fait de me
faire opérer sinon j'aimerais au moins
de 10 ans alors ça pose des petits
problèmes quand vous allez voir votre
banquier votre assurance votre assureur
qui vous dit bon on va vous faire une
cotisation ça va être le double de la
cotisation normal parce que vous allez
mourir mais on vous couvre pas par
contre ça sert à rien de mettre la dot
de cotisation si vous ne trouverez pas
non mais c'est comme ça bon voilà puis
c'est obligatoire bon d'accord voilà et
donc du coup j'ai décidé quand je me
suis lancée dans la vie est d'abord dans
la vie étudiante et ensuite dans la vie
professionnelle de quasiment rien
interdire c'est à dire que j'ai commencé
à travailler quand ça me plaisait pas
changer de boulot donc vous faites une
fois vous le faites deux fois vous
verrez enfin je vous laisse faire et
découvrir de votre propre vie mais vous
avez une expérience il votre cv une
première expérience qui dure neuf mois
puis une deuxième qui dure neuf mois
puis une troisième
ça fait donc dix thèses ne seriez pas un
peu instable quand même un garçon j'ai
un stop non mais quand j'ai un truc à
dire je lui dis donc voilà et puis au
bout d'un moment on essaie de se calmer
de se poser de rester trois ans dans une
même entreprise c'est long trois ans
quand même mais on essaie de rester
trois ans dans une même entreprise
puis à la fin on décide d'aller se
mettre à son compte
parce que on a essayé de faire des
bâtiments un petit peu mieux isolés que
les autres et puis comme disait fabio
tout à l'heure non on a vendu de
l'isolation par l'intérieur qui fait de
l'isolation par l'intérieur qui nous
rend ce point de semer la zizanie dans
le bâtiment wayne on pourrait pas être
plus tôt de mettre 10 cm wattel m 12 13
cm donc tu on a vendu 10 tu fais disent
d'accord puis à un moment donné bon une
fois de plus c'est pour moi qui pars
mais c'est je me fais virer
je décide de me mettre à mon compte et
puis dans l'idée c'est de dire je vais
faire des bâtiments mais de faire des
bâtiments comme si c'était pour moi un
petit peu mieux isoler un petit peu
différemment je suis pas originaire de
la région j'ai pas grandi ici j'ai fait
juste la dernière partie de mes études
ici donc je me dis si je fais la même
chose que mes confrères et néanmoins
concurrents au même prix quel va être
l'intérêt des donneurs d'ordre actuel de
pas travailler avec leurs copains alors
que je propose le même produit donc ça a
été un petit peu ça le premier fil
conducteur
la deuxième chose ensuite ça a été de
dire ben on va faire des bâtiments un
petit peu mieux isolés puis après à
force de chercher un petit peu de
regarder s'ils existent on est allé vers
des bâtiments passifs bâtiment passif
c'est des bâtiments vous avait pas de
chauffage classique
rien n'est certain vous que j'aurai en
tp bientôt à l'iut dont je vous
expliquerai ce pc mais on travaille pas
suivant la rt 2012 qui est grosso modo
une dos parce que
des sources mêmes de mon assureur 50%
des bâtiments qui sont faits suivants la
rt 2012 sont en déclarations de
sinistres c'est à dire que la
performance qu'on a annoncé n'est pas
atteinte
ce qui pour le client le maître d
ouvrage jane eyre une certaine
satisfaction
et donc j'ai fait des bâtiments des
bâtiments différents donc une sortie de
l'entraînement du cadre du dtu et des
normes
une fois que je suis sorti de ce cadre
là eh ben j'ai rencontré le cstb avec
grand plaisir et le cstb on vous dit
vous avez fait un nouveau produit alors
le loup au fait j'ai développé un
nouveau produit qui s'appelle
effectivement les panneaux almere et ce
nouveau produit là plutôt que de refaire
sur chaque chantier le détail de l'appui
de fenêtre parce que globalement c'est
un petit peu ça qu'on fait quand on est
à bac +5 en termes d'études voulait le
bon le détail de l'appui de fenêtre on
va peut-être au bout de 80 ou 100 fois
qu'on a dessiné on peut peut-être dire
on l'a bien à qui on va passer au delà à
d'autres choses plus intéressantes comme
la performance énergétique de nos de nos
bâtiments
pour gérer les problèmes de mise en
oeuvre pour gérer les problèmes de
qualité et e
de maniabilité des matériaux qu'on
utilise pour être capable de garantir la
performance de nos bâtiments
il faut peut être repenser la manière
dont on le fait donc on a fait nos
panneaux de façade tout laisserait voir
sur youtube il ya une petite vidéo qui
qui traînent sur les panneaux elmer ce
que sait comment ça se fabrique et donc
on a fait ce bâtiment là on a fait ce
procédé là on l'a fait breveter s'est
passé en europe aux états-unis sans
problème ça m'a pris deux heures de
temps deux heures de temps c'est un jour
houleux les trains roulaient et où j'ai
pris le train entre dijon et paris j'ai
écrit mon brevet ça tient sur cinq pages
avec les justifications techniques etc
après j'ai mis six ans à justifier
ouvrir au cstb
mais quand je dis justifié il faut aller
batailler il faut aller expliqué c'est
là où les relations humaines joue
énormément
c'est allez leur expliquer gentiment
poliment et sans qu'ils en prennent
ombrage que leur avis est tout à fait
fondée mais que éventuellement il
pourrait y avoir une autre manière de
voir les choses
typiquement dans les panneaux de façade
il me disait de votre panneau il faut le
tester sur la jonction que j'avais créé
entre les panneaux si oui mais comme les
panneaux sont ancrés dans les niveaux de
la du bâtiment si j'ai un mouvement
différentiel entre deux panneaux ça veut
dire que le bâtiment se sépare en deux
si le bâtiment se sépare en deux c'est
pas mon panneau qui valait retenir c'est
la structure qui est derrière donc votre
essai ne sert à rien donc expliquer le
gentil mon nom avec ce que c'est vous
aurez un avis défavorable etc
j'ai pris mon avis défavorable mais j'ai
mis quatre mois à négocier auprès de la
directrice du lycée st b puis ensuite
auprès du directeur des essais du cstb
qu'effectivement c'était s'était pas
justifiée donc j'ai pris du temps pour
prendre le rendez vous je suis allé leur
expliquer et finalement dans son bureau
j'ai à peu près de deux minutes comme je
viens de vous le faire devant vous il
m'a regardé mais oui bien sûr vous avez
raison bon donc il faut le s'obstiner un
petit peu faut pas lâcher quand vous
pensez que vous avez raison il faut pas
lâcher faut y mettre les formes mais
faut pas lâcher
et comme ça vous ça vous permet de
pouvoir arriver et de pouvoir défendre
vos idées si vous êtes convaincu du bien
fondé de vos idées
le fait est que
alors si on vous dit un avis technique
au cstb ça coûte 35000 euros
c'est juste l'instruction de l'avis
technique après ya tous les essais qui
vous demande donc au total en cinq six
ans j'ai dépensé cinq cent cinquante
mille euros pour un avis technique ce
qui est un beau frein à l'innovation et
quelque part alors dans un sens ils sont
nécessaires parce que ça permet de
justifier que ce que vous avez fait dire
la route
donc on a fait des essais au feu on
écoute fait trois heures ont un
affaiblissement acoustique de soixante
sept décibels on a un air de 10 quand il
à la rt 2012 vous demande à air de 6
mais on l'a fait par exemple le siège de
pelletier à aix les bains au bord de
l'autoroute le bâtiment rouge et a dream
et oscar à fond
quand vous regardez vous êtes au bord de
l'autoroute vous entendez par
l'autoroute quand vous êtes à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
mine de rien c'est pas négligeable quand
vous êtes à côté des fenêtres vous
sentez par le froid
j'attendais tout à l'heure à côté de la
porte là je pense que l'étudiant qui est
la voie la regarder le monsieur il est
tout bleu là bas voilà c'est
l'étanchéité à l'air c'est important ça
sert à rien de mettre sa d'isolant dans
un bâtiment si vous avez des trous comme
ça dedans c'est que des choses simples
et j'ai expliqué c'est un mes clients en
disant moi je mets prend beaucoup de
technique
je fais des choses qui sont très simples
mais plus c'est simple moi ça tourne
rond pas les moyens besoin de les
dépanner
c'est juste pour mon confort personnel
mais j'ai pas envie le dimanche soir
d'aller voir parce qu'il ya des
problèmes de fuite parce que la choisir
démarre pas je n'ai pas choisi et donc
comme ça j'ai pas de souci et je mets de
l'isolant je le redis lisant ça coûte
pas cher ça tombe pas en panne ya pas de
maintenance n'est pas d'abonnement et
comme ça je suis tranquille et les gens
arrivent à comprendre ça et c'est se
mettre à la hauteur de vos
interlocuteurs se mettre à la place de
vos interlocuteurs également parce que
globalement
avoir des bâtiments qui consomment très
peu c'est quand même une seule une
comment dire un plaisir et une qualité
de vie qui est quand même importante
j'ai des bâtiments qui tourne au bout de
cinq ans que j'entends de voir les
clients par hasard est une hydre
actualité vous que je vous dise mon
bâtiment 800 m² 700 euros de chauffage
par an thierry combien vous consommez
chez vous - 2 1 euros du mètre carré par
an de chauffage si vous un appartement
de 15 mètres carrés ou un logement une
chambre de 15 mètres carrés c'est à dire
que vous vous chauffez pour 14 euros par
an est ce que vous êtes sûr que
direz-vous déjà vous avez 50 euros
d'abonnement donc enfin voila c'est
penser à ça c'est pas parce qu'on vous
dit que c'est impossible que ça l'est
il faut essayer d'aller chercher dans
les derniers retranchements de la
science et de la technique
ce qu'on est capable de faire s'il ya
des choses qui n'existent pas inventé
les c'est possible aussi de les inventer
c'est un long parcours
mais encore une fois c'est une manière
de se faire plaisir
énormément dans la vie de tous les jours
voilà donc si oui je peux conclure c'est
de dire finalement que innover c'est
très intéressant faire des chances et
technique des chantiers hors norme des
moutons à cinq pattes ya rien de plus
sympa si je peux résumer sort sur une
métaphore de votre âge c'est un peu
comme avec les filles ont su style ça
pour les garçons oubliez que vous n'avez
aucune chance sur un malentendu ça peut
marcher
[Applaudissements]